let's get into today's topics we're
going to start with inflation
i'm not even going to comment until i
read you the nonsense that's going on so
first we have a wall street journal
article that says the white house more
than doubles its inflation forecast in
their new update the administration
expects consumer prices to rise 4.8 in
the fourth quarter from a year earlier
it lists projections for growth this
year and explicitly word for word the
wall street i'm just going to read you
the first three paragraphs or so the
first paragraph says the white house
more than doubled its forecast for
annual inflation and new projections
released friday a supply chain
disruption stemming from the covet 19
pandemic continue to put forward
pressure on prices next says
the office of management budget said it
expected consumer prices would rise 4.8
percent in the fourth quarter from a
year earlier up sharply from the two
percent rise at the biden administration
forecast in may so time out for a second
they said two percent in may now they're
saying that it's going to rise 4.8
officials see those price pressures
quickly abating next year with the
consumer price index rising 2.5 in the
fourth quarter of 2022 more than the 2.1
percent they expected in may reaching
2.3 in 2023. so
pause for a second two percent rise
was expected in may for the fourth
quarter now we're going to 4.8 percent
more than double what they were
expecting and then now we are also
saying that in 2022 a year from the
fourth quarter of this year we are gonna
have 2.5
so a year later it's still going to be
higher than what their expectation in
may was for q4 of 2021. let's continue
next the updated projections are
consistent with other independent
forecasts including the federal reserve
and reflect the administration's view
that price pressures while higher than
expected earlier this year are likely to
fade over time administration officials
said friday wait a second
they're now saying oh we agree with
everybody else and uh this is gonna fade
over time interesting next is a quote
that says
we think this trajectory is very
consistent with the inflation outlook
we've been discussing pretty much since
we got here time out time out time out
we are not going to get gas lit by these
people we think this trajectory is very
much consistent with the inflation
outlook we've been discussing pretty
much since we got here what are you
talking about your expectation for q4 in
2021 was two percent and now you're
saying it's 4.8 percent it's almost it's
more than double what you said it was
gonna be what do you mean it's very
consistent with the inflation outlook
you were off
by literally
two and at point eight percent
that's not consistent you can't just say
oh this is consistent we always thought
this was going to happen and then more
than double your forecast that's not how
it works you were wrong inflation is way
higher than you originally thought be
accountable and say that don't tell us
that this is consistent with what we've
been saying no it's not you just
increased it by more than 2x so
because i won't let them gaslight us and
because the internet never forgets i
went back and i personally the best
business show research team they're
amazing joe and john are great heads i
took it into my own hands today i was
not relying on anybody else i went on
the google machine and i went back and i
found
just all the way back to july not even
that long ago july 19th of
this year the remarks from president
biden on the economy this is from the
white house
website this is on the white house
website the first quote now i want to be
clear my administration understands that
if we were ever to experience unchecked
inflation over the long term that would
pose real challenges to our economy so
while we're confident that isn't what we
are seeing today we're going to remain
vigilant about any response that is
needed rational fair next quote if we
make a prudent multi-year investments in
better roads bridges transit systems and
high-speed internet and a modern
resilient electric grid these steps will
enhance our productivity raising wages
without raising prices that won't
increase inflation it will take the
pressure off of inflation and give a
boost to our workforce which leads to
lower prices in the years ahead time out
time out
four weeks ago you were telling us that
we were gonna have lower prices in the
years ahead
now you're telling us that in q4 of 2022
it's going to be 2.5 percent inflation
which is the rate of change from when
you're telling us is 4.8 today that's
like compound growth today's prices are
going to be 4.8 percent higher than they
were in q4 last year in 2020 and then
they're going to be two and a half times
higher or 2.5 percent higher in q4 of
2022
the data that they are telling us and
that now the white house is projecting
goes directly in contrast with exactly
what the president was claiming on july
19th of this year
and then on top of it they are trying to
gaslight us and tell us that they've
always said that this is consistent with
their belief but you know what that
wasn't good enough i went all the way
back to may again i personally went and
looked at it the best business show
research team the best but i had to go
do it today and then i went and i found
this which is a cnn article and this is
just a screenshot this isn't me
interpreting in any way then other than
what they wrote biden official no sign
of long-term inflation the white house
is pushing back on these inflation
jitters remember they said two percent
in q4 of this year now they're saying
4.8 percent
but back then in may they were saying is
pushing back on these inflation jitters
quote we expect temporary imbalances
between supply and demand whether it is
fewer rental cars available at first or
fewer airline flights as airlines move
back to their regular schedules a white
house official told cnn business on
tuesday these are signs of recovery
although the biden official acknowledged
specific supply chain bottlenecks will
take time to sort out the official added
quote we do not see signs of persistent
dislocation or long-term inflation
our team closely monitors inflationary
pressures but inflation is first and
foremost under the purview of the
federal reserve the official told cnn
business so here is what i don't
understand
how can you in may
say
that this is simply signs of recovery
that this is actually good that this is
happening that we do not see signs of
persistent dislocation or long-term
inflation and then in july you come back
and you say things like if we make a
prudent multi-year investment it will
bring down prices in the years ahead
so obviously you are concerned but to
then in august tell us and gaslight us
that this has been consistent with your
view
is outrageous but this is what happens
nobody calls these people out on what
they are saying or doing if in may you
weren't worried but now you have more
than doubled your expectation of
inflation in q4 of this year are we
worried now
or has this always been consistent with
your view
it's probably more the former than the
latter on top of that if we still have
2.5 inflation which is 25
more than the federal reserve's target
of two percent
in q4 of 2022
does that qualify as long-term higher
inflation
how do we define long-term
well that would have been two and a half
years after the recession ended
remember the recession last year ended
in april
of 2020
so in q4 of 2022 we'll have been two and
a half years later and we'll still have
25 higher inflation than the federal
reserve's target
is that not long-term do we have to have
inflation higher than the federal
reserve's target for a decade does that
qualify as long term
the thing is that what we are watching
is we are watching the manipulation of
words we're watching the leveraging of
vernacular and we are watching the
gaslighting of the american people
because the economics of what is
occurring does not match with a theory
of what is supposed to happen
based on their understanding
you cannot manipulate interest rates
down to zero
and artificially keep them depressed
and then at the same time also create
trillions of dollars and stuff it into
every corner of the economy
and expect that inflation won't be a
problem
we know that inflation is a problem it's
over five percent in the cpi terms it's
over four percent in core inflation
these are the highest levels either 13
years for cpi or 30 years for core
inflation how can you not be worried how
can you say that it's not a problem
on top of that if you are forced to
increase your expectations by more than
double to go from two percent to four
point eight percent
how can you say that it's consistent
with what you've always thought
the numbers it it is
impossible for you to say this was
consistent you just more than doubled
what your forecast is so obviously
something is different
and again i don't blame these people i
don't blame the organizations or the
institutions this stuff is hard
but i think the better approach is not
to say oh we've always thought this or
we've always been consistent here
instead the better approach is to simply
say
this is a complex economic machine
there's a lot of inputs and there's a
lot of outputs we are doing the best we
can with the information that we have at
any time we have a lot of smart people
we look at a lot of data and we do our
best we reserve the right to change our
mind in the future and because we are
presented with more information we've
changed our mind that is a sign of
intellectual capabilities and
open-mindedness rather than sticking to
a rigid thought process or theory in
which we are willing to go down with the
ship
people would be much more receptive to
that story they would understand they
would say listen i personally can't do
any better i don't think i or my
brothers could do any better than they
are
but what i do think is the problem and
the reason why people are losing trust
with these institutions and with these
individuals
is the fact that they continue to say
things like
it is consistent with what we've always
thought
it's not it's very provably not
consistent and so instead of living in a
world where politicians continue to just
say things and everyone whitewashes
history or simply says of course that's
what they've always thought
with the internet with social media and
young people they now know
we can check we can verify the
information and what we find is that
this is not consistent and the more that
they claim it is the less and less we
trust them the less and less we believe
what they're going to say in the future
and so ultimately the secret to these
folks establishing trust and keeping
trust and keeping the ear of the
american people is they have to remain
accountable they have to remain
transparent and they simply have to tell
the truth
just explain to everyone this is hard it
is a complex economic machine and we are
going to get it wrong actually we're
going to get it wrong more than we're
going to get it right it's kind of like
predicting the weather the weather folks
nobody holds them accountable when
they're wrong about predicting the
weather because it's really really
difficult on top of that we understand
that the inputs and information will
change
and we understand that you can't point
to one thing it's not just monetary
policy fiscal policy or supply chains
it's everything being analyzed in
totality simply tell us the data changed
so we changed our mind do not gaslight
us and tell us that you've always
believed this that is consistent hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.compomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more the best business show we're going
to build the biggest business show in
the world and we need your help
[Music]